[Music]
welcome to the QuickStart for cloud pick
table on the big table page select
create instance under instance name type
quick start instance this should Auto
populate the instance ID for you for
this quick start select development as
the instance type under zone select Us
East 1c then click create
once the instance has been created open
Google Cloud shell and after it's
initialized type in G cloud components
update followed by G cloud components
installed CBT then insert the project
and instance information into the CBT RC
file we can now create our first big
table by calling CBT create table my -
table we can confirm its creation by
typing CBT Ellis we will now create a
new family for the table and call it CF
1 we can confirm its creation by typing
CBT LS my - table now we can use the CBT
set command to set a key value pair in
our table and use CBT read to verify
that the key value was stored properly
congratulations you've completed the
QuickStart
[Music]